We're going to open up the Network tab in DevTools to start off.
The Network tab gives us a list of all the requests and
responses fired off by the browser in loading and rendering a Web page.
If we're recording as the Web page loads,
we'll see all sorts of resources that the website needs.
We see images, we see JavaScript files, and we even see some CSS.
In a moment, I'm going to stop and then start recording to get a fresh slate.
When we scroll down as far as we can, we'll hit a quick pause and
then all the sudden, new content will appear.
In Network, we're going to see that request show up.
Let's go ahead and try it.
I will stop and start recording And scroll down.
There we go.
We could see it right there.
All right, let's see what we have in here.
We can see a request happen right here.
Let's click on it.
This request is called PagePostSectionPagelet.
And look, it's even got the word ajax inside the u, request URL.
At this point, I'm going to switch to some written instructions so
you can follow along with me.
I recommend opening up two browser windows side by side.
That way, you can follow along in Facebook in one window while you've got
the instructions from Udacity in the other.